Labyrinth then you went to Labyrinth
yeah David Bowie was amazing he was
amazing well he was amazing I don't
think I I really
I think I was
I think I was shy and I sort of I cover
up shyness by being business-like or
something you know yeah I think so I
think that had I really allowed myself
to just go wow
do you think he could have made love to
David Bowie well I could have I don't
know if David could have done it to me
but why not well I don't know but I
think he's once they said are you uh
bisexual he says I'm trisexual sorry
everything he he's amazing
um no he was so cool he was so cool just
because he was um so unpretentious yeah
and so gifted I mean there's very few
people who could pull off that character
I wanna yeah you know really I love
David Bowie yeah I loved his last video
my God that was the documentary well
don't which his last music video he made
oh yeah yeah Lazarus I mean it's just
like amazing yeah he was revolutionary
he really was he really was was there
any one particular story that you
remember with David well what I remember
is he came in looking really tired uh
one morning and I was like okay so we're
gonna start and do this and he went I'm
tired he said yeah Mick and I were up
all night we shot the video dancing in
the streets last night and hadn't slept
and I'm like this this like the fan girl
and me going oh my God I wish I could
have been there and uh
California here that's right that's
amazing